まあ そういうわけで 今日のテーマは
人間と人間間のコミュニケーションということなんです
で なんで仏教の世界でこのコミュニケーションの問題を取り扱いますかということも問題なんですけど
それは普通の世界の仕事ではないかなと
でも それ仏教にも大変大事なテーマなんです
コミュニケーションというのはどういうものかということ
一応経典 今日調べてないんですけど
経典の中ではもう大変きめ細かく
まあそういうものをお話はしているところはいろいろあります
で あの仏教の世界っていうのは
人間が心を清らかにして悟るという悟りという状況を作るための道なんですが
あるいは違う言葉で言えば
人間の苦しみをどのように乗り越えられるかという
我々味わっている生きる苦しみを乗り越える方法なんですね
ですから 生きる苦しみを乗り越える方法として
このコミュニケーションということも大変重大な役割をしているんです
ですから 今日はこの言語学的な話というよりも
普通どう喋ればいいかとかね
そういう具体的な話より
心を清らかにするという目的に基づいて
我々の苦しみをなくすというテーマに中心にして
そのテーマをいくらかお話をしたいと思います
で あの大体まあよく毎日のように見ている顔を見ると
話が知らないうちにすごい難しくなりますから
この新しい顔を見ると
まあ基本的なところは喋れますけど
で  まあコミュニケーションというのは大体まあこういうことなんですね
私を相手が理解してほしいという気持ちありますね
私のことを理解してくださいということと
もう一つは 私が相手のことを理解したいと
で 私の気持ちわかってくれと
相手の気持ちもわかりたい
理解したいということは
まあ一応コミュニケーションなんですね
で まあそれでできますかと
我々にとっては という問題なんですね
その前に私が こういう疑問を作りたいんですよ
なんで自分の気持ちを
相手にわかって欲しがるんですかね
どうか私のことを理解してくださいとなぜ願うのか
なぜ自分の気持ちは相手に理解されないとそんなに苛立つのか
そこを考えて まず考えた方がいいんじゃないかなと
次に次のステップなんですね
そこは我々の問題なんですね
私たちは自分の気持ちを相手が理解してもらわないと
かなり苛立っちゃうんですよ
ものすごく嫌な気持ちになるんですね
あれ 何でしょうかね 別に自分の気持ちを理解しなくても
どうったことないんじゃないかなと思いますけど
それではうまくいかないんですね
どうしても自分の気持ちをわかってほしいと思っちゃうんですね
それはどうでしょうかね
皆様方にも同じ問題あるでしょう
なんでそう思うんですかね
なんで我々は私のことを理解してくださいと
私の気持ちをわかってちょうだいと思うんですかね
あまり答えが出てこないんだから
まああの一応考えてみてください
もう真剣に なんで私が私の気持ちをわかってちょうだいと思うんですかと
それで私は答えを申し上げます
私たちが相手を支配したいんですよ
だから自分の気持ちを分かったところで
相手が自分の気持ちに沿って行動しなくちゃいけないんですね
例えば それをお母さんと子供の例で言えば
お母さんの気持ちもちょっと分かってくれという場合は
子供が自分自由自在に行動するんじゃなくて
お母さんの気持ちに沿って行動を変えなくちゃいけないんですよ
だから自分の気持ちを分かってくれと言うんです
そういう単純な例で考えてみてください
あまり複雑に考える必要はないんです
ですから 我々は私の気持ちを分かってくれという場合は
すごく謙虚的な まあすごくまあ弱そうな顔をして喋ってはいるんだけど
少々私の気持ちを分かってくれればいいなとかね
なんか全然悪くないような
すごく優しい すごく謙虚的で
そういう気持ちでは言ってるんだけど
その裏にあるのは相手を支配したいという
あの その気持ちなんですね
その権力 相手を管理したい
支配したいという気持ちなんですね
だから一見表では綺麗なことで聞こえますけど
ちょっと 1枚開けてみると
なんかちょっとやばいような
ことなんですよ そこでお母さんと子供の例でそうなんですけど
大人の社会でも同じことなんですよ
社会の中でも我々は自分の気持ちを分かってくれというと
その人を思う通りに行動しなくちゃいけないんですね
例えば 政治家の方々の気持ちはわかってほしいと思っちゃうと
我々はその政治家が言っていることを正当化して応援しなくちゃいけないことになっちゃうんです
それでこういうケースどうですか？よくあなたの気持ちは分かりました
でも私は絶対反対だよと
それには そのそう言われると
私は言うのは全然わかってないんだと
また お母さんの例で言っちゃうと
もう子供がお母さん言うことよくわかります
でもやりませんと言ったら
お母さんの反応は あんた全然お母さんの気持ちはわかってないんだという反応なんです
大人の社会でも 我々は大人同士で
あんた言わんとすることはよくわかります
でも私は反対ですと言ったら
うん わかってないんだと思っちゃうんですよ
だからわかってくれと
わかってちょうだいと思うと
そこにあるのは相手を支配する
いう この支配 何でしたっけ？それは
あ 支配力ですね じゃあ
それで どこで問題が起こるかというと
支配されてほしい人はいいんですよ
支配されてほしくない人の場合はトラブル起きちゃうんですね
それは一つ それから 本来
我々は本当は誰にも支配されて欲しくないんですよ
人間っていうのは どんな生命でも
自分がすごく独立していて
自分の自由で生きているんだと思っているんですよ
まあ事実はどうか分かりませんだけど
どんな我々飼っているペットでも
犬でも猫でも 本当は自分勝手で
自分好きな通りに生きているんだということを思っているんです
そういうふうにさせないとペットも攻撃するんですよ
例えば 外へ散歩したがっている犬を我々は縛っておく
そうすると犬が吠えちゃうんですね
鳴くんです 攻撃するんですよ
猫もそうでしょうし ですから
どんな動物さえも 自分たちが自分の意思で
自分の自由自在で生きているんだということは事実なんですね
ですから 本来は支配して欲しくないんですよ
私が私の道を歩むんだと
誰も何も言うなよという気持ちなんですね
生命っていうのは ですから
自分の気持ちをわかってくれということは
なかなか世の中でうまくいくはずがないんです
大体攻撃になるんです
そこで じゃあ支配される人々は何なのかと
いるでしょう もう例えば犬でも捨てた子犬でも
人間 どんな人間でも見たらすぐ尻尾を振って
振って まあかわいい顔をしてくれるでしょうね
店で売ってるペットでも
人間も見学に行ったらみんなすごいかわいい顔をしてくれるでしょうに
だからもうなんとなく買うことできなくても
なんか買えばいいなという気持ちになるんですよ
買ってあげたいなとかね
そうすると そのペットが
その動物が本当に人に飼われて欲しがっているんですかと
本当はあれ ずるいんですよ
買わ買ってもらわなきゃ自分の生計は成り立たないんですよ
あれ 自分の自由を私たちに渡したわけじゃないんです
逆に私たちを束縛するだけ
ペットが見たら 犬が見たらあまりにも可愛くて
ものすごく馴染んできましたと
そうすると情が出てきて
やっぱり買ってしまうと
結局は買われてしまうんです
ですから この人間の世界でも
あ あなた言うことを何でもやるそうと
いう場合も これ自分の生計はそれによって成り立つのですよ
例えば 奥さん言うことを何でも旦那さんが聞くと
その場合は聞かないんだったら大変なことになるんですよ
平和で幸せで生きていたあの環境は崩れてしまうんですね
だから何でも聞くと そんなことになるんですね
子供も小さい時はすごく可愛いんですね
何でも聞く なんでそんなことするんですか？と謝ってくださいと言ったら
何のこともなくすごい可愛い顔をしてごめんなさいと言うんですね
ごめんなちゃいと言うんですけど
でも大きくなったらそれないでしょ
だからちっちゃな子供は
まあ何のこともなく すごく丁寧にごめんなさいと言ったんだからといって
その子はすごく言うことよく聞いてくれる子供だよと思ったら
それは違います 大きくなったら逆なんですから
喧嘩するんだから ごめんなさいは消えちゃうんです
ですから この支配されているような感じの人々も
結局はあれはずるいやり方なんです
自分の身を守るためにやっているちょっとした手段なんですね
あの 今選挙運動だから皆様に分かりやすいますけど
例えば政治の世界で大きな党に小さな党が合体したりするでしょうに
大きな党の政策やら全て認めて
みんなに支配されるようにされてもいいということではないんですよ
自分を自分の党を存続するための手段なんですよ
議席を減らないための手段なんです
強くなるための手段なんですよ
それできなくなっちゃうと
また分かれちゃう また離党するというか
分離しちゃうんです はい
それで理解してほしいなのはそういうこと
で 私たちは私の気持ちを理解してちょうだいと思うところで
自分の心の中にあるのは
相手を支配したいという支配力ということ
で 相手支配して何が悪いかということもありますけど
何が悪いじゃなくて 支配できないんですよ
世の中で 支配できないんです
他人のことを管理できないんですよ
だからトラブルが起こるんですよ
例えば 家庭を持ってるお母さんというのは大変でしょ
旦那さんと子供とみんな支配しなくちゃいけないんだから
もう大変なんですよ 結構ヒステリー起こしたりする
そこで大勢の人々を管理している人々というのはもっと大変なんです
例えば 国の総理大臣のような一番上の管理者だったら
ものすごい大変なんです
だから なかなか人を支配するということはなかなか楽な仕事じゃないんです
もう苦しみの元 いろんな喧嘩が起きたりするも
いろんな物別れになったりする
もういろいろなんです
そこで結果としてどうなるかというと
自分の自由が消えちゃうんですよ
矛盾になっちゃうんです
例えば 家の奥さんがもうしっかりした奥さんで
すごい仕事をよくできて
もう何でも綺麗に管理しているんだと
子供の面倒であろうか
旦那のことであろうか
姑さんのことであろうか
舅さんのことであろうか
もう親戚のことで全部テキパキとやってるんだと
一見すごくよくよくもできた奥さんではないかなと見えますけど
もうちょっと調べてみると
あの奥さんには何の自由もないんです
何の自由もなくなっちゃうんですよ
例えば 私がこういうところで自由に喋れますけど
日本の 例えば政党の人々が自由に喋れますか？何人か自分の感情を喋ったところで
もうクビになったんですからね
1年前かちょっと前 何か外国について
韓国について 中国についてなんかちょっと発言して
別に普通の人そういう発言したってもどうったことないんですよ
発言されたところで もうクビになるようになってしまっちゃったんです
で で まあ東京の知事もいろいろ大胆な発言をする方なんですけど
一旦発言したら結構問題起きたりする
でも 東京都の知事にしてもすごく偉い方なんでしょうに
もうかなりの人々の管理者でしょうに
そこでたくさん人を管理しているんだけど
結局自分が人を支配しているかというと逆になっているんですよ
自由にしゃべることさえできなくなっちゃうんですよ
これは最悪なのは この総理大臣みたいな
この全体的に管理する人なんですね
一言葉 一言葉 ずっと気をつけて気をつけてしゃべらないと
例えば ものすごい忙しくて
もう睡眠不足で外出かけると
もうちょっと誰か何か聞いたら
うるさい あんたあっち行きなさいと取る一言葉でも言ったら
次の日もう終わりなんです
新聞でも一番大きなキャプションになってしまっちゃって
だからいかに大変かと理解してください
この人を支配したいと
このすごいいい気持ちで思っちゃいますけど
あれはすごい誤解なんです
人を支配して全然いいことにはなりません
結局は自分の自由はなくなっちゃうんですよ
だから生命は本来自由に行動したい
自由に行動したいと思っています
その上 自分の自由を確保したく
私の気持ちもわかってくださいと他人に頼む
わかってもらったら もうその人を支配する
逆に自分の自由がなくなっちゃう
で それわからないんだったら
またお母さんと子供の例で考えちゃう
考えましょう もしお母さん言うことを子供が聞いてくれたら
すぐに子供の欲求があるでしょ
私はお母さん言うことよく聞いてるんだから
お母さん言う通りに勉強しているんだから
私にこのおもちゃ買ってくれと
このゲームを買ってくれと言ったら
お母さんにはどうすることもできない
あなた言うこと何も私は聞いてあげません
でも私言うこと聞きなさいと言ったりも成り立ちません
だから自分が結局束縛されちゃう
だからただ答えは人を支配したいという気持ちを捨てることなんですよ
それなかなか難しいんです
人を支配したいという気持ちを捨てちゃえば
自分が自由になるんです
でも 自分一人だけ その時は自由な人
人はもう孤独です どうしますかね
で 支配したいという気持ちなくなっちゃうと
別に自分の気持ちはわかってもわからなくたっても
まあどうったことはないんです
で 次のこの問題の次の側面はこういう側面なんですね
私が相手の気持ちを理解したいんだと
相手の気持ちはなんでかわからないんだという場合は何でしょうか
なんで我々は人の気持ちを理解したくなるんですかね
それも同じなんです その人を管理したいんです
その人を管理したい 支配したい
だから相手の気持ちもわかりたくなるんです
でも逆に もし相手の気持ちがわかってしまえばどうなるかというと
自分の自由がなくなっちゃうんです
相手のことがわかってるんだからね
しょうがないんですよ
子供がオートバイに乗りたいという
どうせどんな両親でも反対する
子供のこと可愛いんだから
怪我でもしたらどうしますかと反対するんですけど
もしお母さんかお父さんが子供の気持ちは理解しました
この子はもうそろそろ１６歳にもなっているし
もう大人でしょうし だからまあ友達と一緒に大人の社会でまあちょっと動いた方が
遊んだ方がまあ堂々と育てるだろうと言って
して 子供の気持ちを理解する
やっぱり友達もオートバイ持っているんだからね
やっぱりこれちょっと良くないと
そう理解してた途端どうなるかというと
子供にオートバイを買ってあげなくちゃいけないことになっちゃうんです
だから相手の気持ちを理解するということは
自分の自由が失うということなんです
そこでもうもうきれいに考えてみましょう
人間というのは 生命というのは本来自由に生きていきたいという気持ちを持っている
その上 自分の気持ちもわかってほしくて
相手の気持ちも理解したがる
これ成り立ちますかと
どちらかにしないと 両立できません
これ 水と火のようなものなんですよ
一緒にはならないんです
例えば この夫婦 互いにすごく理解し合うということはあるでしょうね
夫婦はお互いに理解すればするほど
お互いにべったしとものすごく束縛されるんですよ
あまり理解しないと離婚で終わっちゃうんですね
だからどちらがいいということではなくて
あの もし自分が自由だ自由だと思っちゃったら
結婚生活はあまり長持ちはしません
互いに気持ちをものすごく理解し合ったならば
もう死ぬまで一緒にいられるんですが
まあ自由はなくなっちゃうんですね
ですから まず最初のポイントはそういうポイントなんです
生命が 生命は本来自由に独立して生きていきたいという気持ちがある
これは本能としてあります
それで理解していない
自分のことを分かっていないんだから
自分の気持ちを理解してくれと
それから相手の気持ちを理解したいという気持ちが生まれてきて
せっかくの自由が失っちゃう
そこで結果として 人間であろうか
どんな生命であろうか
いつでも混乱の中で生きているんです
混乱ない人生はありません
いろいろ問題やらトラブルやら
いろんなぶつかり合い
いろんなものが起きてきますね
人生の中で だからそれは永遠な問題
だから苦しみの元になっちゃうんですね
理解はしたいんだけど
理解すればするほど自分の問題が大きくなる
自分のことを理解すればするほど
自分が人に支配されるようになってしまう
それもまあ言い忘れちゃったんだけど
自分のことをよくみんなわかってるんだと言っちゃうと
自分のプライバシーは全部消えてるんですよ
私の気持ちをわかってくれとわかってちょうだいと思っていても
もしわかってもらったら
自分のプライバシーはなし
と同時に私のプライバシーではないかとまた威張ったりする
どっちでしょうかね プライバシーを守り
守りたければ もう自分の気持ちを相手にわからないようにすることですね
相手に読まれたらもう自分の自由がないんですよ
だから相手に読まれることも
相手を読むことも 結局は本来生命が希望している自由というものを
気持ちがなくなるということになります
そこで そのポイントを繰り返しします
それについて何か疑問とか疑いとかあるならば聞いてもいいんですけど
はい  理解したいって割と思う方だと思ってるんですが
はい その人の本当の心が違うとするためだっていうのがうん
見えるかもしれないけれども
そしたら人間のみんな
その自由を守っちゃうというと
人間性がなくなっちゃう
うんっていう気が  はい
うん まあまあ それはまあ
そのように考えられます
うん 例えば自分にはおっしゃるように支配したい気持ち
それもあまり納得いかないんですよ
ね 例えば 自分が人のことを理解したい
理解したいんだけど 別に支配したいという気持ち本当にあるかと
それ納得いかないんです
ですから もう厳密に考えないと
だからこれ 仏教の我々は悟りの世界
悟りの立場から今喋ってるんです
お釈迦様がおっしゃった解脱の
そこを中心にして今話してますよ
ですから いろいろちょっと納得いかない
納得いかないところは結構あります
今おっしゃった疑問もその通りです
私もそれはまあその通りだと思います
我々は人の気持ちを理解したいんであって
別にその人を支配したいという気持ちはないと
ただ親切な行為ではないかと
もっと良い人間の生き方ではないかと思ってるんです
だから 1枚をちょっと外してみてくださいと
外したら いや 外さなくても
もし相手のことを理解しちゃうとどうなるんですかね
結果として 相手の犬も目になっちゃうんですよ
なぜならば 例えば相手がもう借金で苦しんでいるんだと
その苦しみ 私は理解したとする
そうすると その人が来て
あなたもわかってるでしょ？私はどんなに苦しんでいるんですかと
そう よくわかってるんです
って言ったら お金をあげなくちゃいけなくなる目になっちゃうんです
だからやっぱり自分の自由がなくなっちゃうんですね
はい  私自分でずっと思うんですけど
人のことがよくわからない自分はなんて冷たい人間だろうってずっと思ったりして
それをうまく解けない
解けないってずっと来たんですけど
うん やっぱり冷たい人間で
世間では冷たい人間は良くないっていうふうになっているから
私自身はやっぱり人の気持ちを分からなきゃいけないのかなと思って生きて考えてきたんです
はいはい でも 矛盾を感じながら
いや そうでもない そうなると自分がリラックスできないなとか
いろんなことを考えながらずっと来たんですよ
うんうん で 今のお話を伺ってて
どんなでしょう  だからまあ人
僕はちっとも理解したいと思わないんですよ
人のことなんて 自分の自分のことを聞いてみると
うん だから冷たい人間かなと思うんですよ
別に妻ともなんとかこうずっとなんとかなれてきてるんですけれど
だからそちらにあるのは
自分が自分の自由はものすごい頑固で守りたいと思ってるんですよ
その自分の自由を守りたいと思っているんだから
まあそういう相手のことをまあ理解しないんだ
冷たい人間やと 世間の言われることを自分の心に入ってくるだけなんですね
だから自分 私が聞きたいのは
ご自分が自分のことを冷たい人間かと思ってますかと
ご自分いかがでしょうか
自分が冷たい人間だと思ってます？ そうじゃないと思っている
うん それでいいんですよ
うん だから自分が冷たい人間ではないというふうに思っているならば
それで十分です  それで今のうちはそれで十分です
本当に冷たいかないかというのは
客観的な情報を調べなきゃわかりませんからね
人のことを理解しなくても
人にそんなに冷たくないんだったら
別にどうったことはない
人が困ったらすぐ自分が手を出すならば
それぐらいで十分ですよ
人のことを知らんと言って放っておく人でないならば
まあそれぐらいで私は十分だと思います
だから世の中で言う言葉っていうのは
みんなただ口で言うだけで意味わかってないんですよ
だから今も私はこの逆説を言ってるんですけど
世の中では相手のことを理解するのは大変ありがたいことやと思っているだけであって
それはどういうものかと明確に分析しない
だから人のことを理解しない人は冷たいんですよと
ただ言うだけで そうじゃなくて
ちゃんと証拠を持って情報を取って喋らなくちゃいけないんですよ
人間っていうのは それをそんなそこまで考えないんですよ
ただもうペラペラ喋る
むちゃくちゃ何か考える
それだけ それは無知なんですね
仏教 仏教という教えはなぜあるかというと
そのいい加減で無知で考える
無知で喋るということをやめて
もっと深みがあるような人生やりましょうと
ということで 私はこういう分析をしているんです
ですから 世間いうことはそんなにも
あの 気にする必要ないんです
だから本当にそうですか？と相手に聞かなくちゃいけない
例えば 誰かが世の中のことを理解しない人は冷たいだよと言ったとする
言ったところで 私がその人に聞く
あなたは本当になぜそう言うんですか？と言ったら
その人は逃げるんですよ
いえ 別に世の中みんなそう言ってるんだよと
みんなそう言ってるんだよと言ったら
誰と話し合えばいいんですかね
よく逃げるんですよ だからあまり相手にならない話なんですね
それでその人はこう言ったら
私がそう思いますよと
相手のことを理解しない人が冷たいんだと私が思いますと言ったならば
その人には逃げられません
そこで私にも聞こえる質問できる
なぜあなたがそのように思いますかと
どういう証拠がありますかと
どんな経験がありますかと聞こえます
聞けますからね ですから
この一般的に言うこの英語でいうとスイーピングステートメントというんだけど
まあ全部いっぺんにまとめて言っちゃうというのは
そういうのはあまり知恵の言葉ではないんですね
ですから まああまり気にしない方がいいと思います
じゃあそのポイントについてまだ疑問があります
ありますか？ああ で しっかり納得いかないということは私も十分わかっています
納得いかないように またかえってわざと喋っているんです
そうすると自分で自分のことを自分で質問してほしい
ただ 私の話を聞いて理解するんじゃなくて
なんか変なことを言われたんだと
なんかちょっと認めたくないんだと
本当かなと それは私は嘘を言っているのではないかと
そういうふうに自分の心の中で考えてほしいんです
そうすると自分の問題は解決します
何かあります？はい  母と子の関係が一番
そのまあ お互い理解し
小さい頃の母っていうのはお互い理解し合っているという気がするんですけど
そうすると母親っていうのはすごく慈悲の心があるっていうことになってくると思うんですが
その支配力っていうのと慈悲の心というのは同一視しないでいいです
それはそうなんですよ
慈悲の心ある母は支配しないんですよ
執着の心ある母は支配しようとする
だから両立しません しません
母にあるべきなのは慈悲であって
子供に対する執着 愛着ではないんです
それは仏教の教えであって
人間みんな実践するかしないかということは別な話で
で この間 他の方と対談がありまして
その子供の問題もあって
私はこの対談が終わってからちょっとまあからかってやろうかなと思って質問したんですね
で 相手が自分の娘がオートバイ乗りたかったんですけど
自分がすごく反対しましたと
反対しますても やっぱり本人がまあオートバイに乗ってるんだと
それで自分が素晴らしい仏教徒だから
もし何かあったら一緒に泣いてあげると
言ったら 私はとんでもないんだと
けしからんだと 私だったら娘がオートバイに乗りたいと言ったならば
んだと 私たちはできるだけあなたはもう立派な健康的な体で育ててあげた
もうあんた大人 もう勝手にしなさいよと
オートバイに乗るなり
ボートに乗るなり 何でも勝手にしなさいよ
もう関係ないんだと こちらに構うなよと
自分が自立しているんだから
自分で責任取れ 私は言ったことはそういうこと
自分で責任取れと言ったら
その方がすごく怒って
なんということですかと
それは決して仏教的でもなんでもないんだと
自分で責任取れたら子供に責任取れませんと
子供はいくら年取っても責任取れませんと
私はひどい父親だな あなたは
ひどいでしょうに だから子供が自分の娘さんが 40歳になって 60歳になっても
この馬鹿者が支配したがってるんだから
あれでいい父親というんですかね
十五 六十歳になっちゃうと
まあもうあなたも大人だから
もう自分の責任で生きてなさいよと言って世界に出すと
そうすると子供はやっぱりもうお母さんも悪く言わないし
父親は何も言わないし
自分がやばいことをやっちゃったら自分がやばいんだと
お母さんに泣いてお母さん助けてちょうだいと言えなくなっちゃうんだと
怒られるんだと だから自分の責任を自分で持つようになるんですよ
それは慈しみであって
いくら年取っても 私の子供は
私の子供はもう離してあげませんというのは
ものすごい汚い 恐ろしい
もう鬼なんですね その方
すごく怒って もうカンカン
私に攻撃しようと思ったんだけど
私はもうすごい もう全部カットしてね
立派な父親じゃないんだと
あんたなんでそう言うんですか？とか言ってくれたら
すごく怒ったところで
ちょっと待ってください
あなたはひどい父親だと思ってるんですかね
私が言ったんだからといって
私はあんたひどい父親と言ったよ
だからあんたひどい父親になるんですかと
あんたどう思ってますかと
いや 私はそう思って だからそれでいいじゃないですかと
そこでもっとこの頭の悪さをもっともう
人に何か言われたんだからって
自分がそうなるわけじゃないでしょうに
でも痛いところをもう私はもう刺しちゃったんだからね
かなりまあ ですから あの質問に答えなんですけど
慈しんで育てるということは
私に生まれてきた子供は別な生命であって
じゃあ私は面倒見てあげるだけですよと
それは面倒見てあげて
社会の一員として育ててあげるんだという
ずっと子供に一人の立派な社会人として生きていられる
自分の足で歩ける 自分の問題自分で解決できるような立派な人として育てることは慈しみであって
いつでもお母ちゃんと泣いてくれるんだったら
もうとんでもないでしょうに
会社にもお母さんと一緒に行くんだったら
あるでしょ 大学入学にもお母さんと一緒に行くとか
あれはもう間違いなんですね
執着ありすぎ だから心配するのは心配しますよ
子供は 50歳になったっても
おばあちゃんが心配しますよ
自分の子供だから これ
心配とあれと違いますよ
子供は社会でなんか失敗しちゃったら
やっぱり母親だから 父親だから
それ悲しいんですよ だからでずっと支配する必要はないんです
ごちゃ混ぜなんですね
私が言ったのは客観的な倫理で
その人が頭が悪いんだからごちゃ混ぜで
それは子供に対する愛情も全部捨てて
もうもう他人同士で考えることを私が言ってるんだと勘違いする
他人になれないでしょうに
いくら子供を追い出しちゃっても
家からもう勘当やと出て行けと言ったっても
子供は子供だから他人になれませんよ
たとえ時々両親が子供勘当するでしょ
勘当したっても 心のどこかでそれでも無事元気で生きていきたいという気持ちはあるんですよ
なぜ勘当するかというと
一緒にいると面倒くさくて
言うことを聞かなくて
だから勘当する それはお前死んでしまえという気持ちじゃないんです
一緒にいるとあなたにも迷惑
私たちにも迷惑だから
一人で頑張ってくださいと
こっち来るなよという勘当さえも両親の慈しみなんですよ
そこを分かってないんですね
それはまあ そこぐらいで十分だと思います
一応 慈しみと支配力っていうのは両立はしません
はい 次にコミュニケーションというのは
言葉の問題で考えましょう
言葉でコミュニケーションするということで
コミュニケーションは 2種類あります
1つはコミュニケーション成り立ちます
例えば 今日は 1 日中雨ですよと
だから傘を持って行ってくださいと人に言う
そうすると私の気持ちが相手は理解する
理解し あ そうですね じゃあ傘持ってきますと
そちらに何のトラブルも起きません
で ご飯用意できましたから食べなさい
言ったら 旦那さんと子供があれ
母何言ってるんですかね
わからないということは絶対ありえません
すぐわかるんです あ もうご飯食べなくちゃいけないと
そういう言葉のやりとりっていうのはちゃんと成り立ちます
ですから そういう言葉のやりとり
いわゆるどういうことかというと
この あの この具体的なこと
具体的な合理的なことだったら
言葉でやりとりできます
で もう一つ例っていうのは
例えば学校に行って我々は勉強する
それ言葉で勉強するんですよ
それは成り立ちます それは感情のやりとりじゃないんだから
数学は先生教える 子供たちも理解する
歴史は先生教える 子供たちもそれを理解する
科学は先生教える 子供たちは理解する
そうやって客観的な事実について語る場合は
大体コミュニケーションというのは成り立ちます
それは一つ もう一つは
この感情のやりとり そのコミュニケーションはなかなか
成り立たないんです 例えば
私がこう言ったら 私はエビなんかは嫌いですよと
皆様方 わかりますかね
私の気持ちは 子供いるでしょうに
ピーマン嫌いとかニンジン嫌いとか
お母さんわかりますかね
その気持ちは そちらにあるのは感情なんですよ
わかりません 私はエビは嫌いですよと
その気持ちは相手にわかりません
それで私は自分が一番好きな食べ物は何ですかと聞かれたら
私は私はやっぱりインド風なカレー
カレー料理が一番美味しいと思ってますよと言っても
日本の方々 それわかりますかね
あの匂いするあの食べ物でしょうとかね
あの辛いものでしょうとか
なんでそれ好きと言うんですかということになるんです
だから今日は雨ですと言ったら分かります
気持ちが通じる 私はエビは嫌いですと言ったら
それは通じないコミュニケーションなんです
そこで この 1番目のコミュニケーションの場合は
誰もあまり問題にしていないんです
電車は 8時30分だよと言ったら
誰もそれ間違わないんですよ
まあ僕みたいな遅刻する連中もいますけど
まあでも間違ってるわけじゃないんで
それは  8時30分に電車が発車しますと
遅刻したっても だから一応世の中で
そこら辺で我々はうまくいってるんです
で みんな困っているのは
この自分の気持ちを分かってほしいということなんです
それは成り立たないんです
私はエビがエビが嫌いと思って
自分の気持ちわかってほしくたっても
わかるわけないと思いますけど
そこで昔 国の大学からある女性の教師が来て
日本で勉強するために肉は全然口にしない
で 私は彼女に聞いて あんた肉食べないんで
魚も食べないんですかと
そしたらまあ魚はまあまあ適当に食べますよと
だったらまあもう別に困ることはないんだと
日本で魚もありますから
もう野菜だけだったら結構あんた困りますよと
でもどこか行って なんか集まりがありまして
日本の方々の そこでいろいろ料理用意してあったんですね
魚もあったんですけど
彼女は何一つ口にしなかったんです
私は魚ですけど なんで食べないんですかと
頭がついてるんです 頭と尻尾ついてもう気持ち悪いけどしょうがないと
だから焼き魚丸ごとにして
塩焼きにして お醤油かけておいしそうに
やっぱり日本の料理は世界一おいしいんだと言いながら食べてる
日本の方々は頭に頭と尻尾ついてるんだから食べたくないと気持ち悪いというあの女性の気持ちわかりますかね
わからないでしょう そこで私が勉強している時の大学の指導教授が我々のことをからかってこういうことを言ったんですよ
もうインドに行ったら
まあインドで まあ日本ではどういう食べ物がありますか？一番まあおいしい魚
食べ物って料理って何ですか？と聞いたところ
先生が自分にとってはこの刺身とかね
すごくおいしいと言ったそうで
刺身って何ですか？とインド人に聞いたらところで
それはまあ生の魚ですよと言ったら
みんなすごいひどい顔をしてえっと言ったそうです
で その話 まあ聞いてます
やっぱり気持ちはわからないんですよ
先生言ったのは インド人が思ったのは
我々はこの生の魚 こうやって取って
こうやってバクバクと
トウモロコシを食べるような感じで食べるだろうというイメージでしたと
そんな感じだったら 日本人はおそらく嫌いでしょうと思いますけど
でも生ものはもういかなる量があっても口にしないと不浄やと思っているインド人にとっては刺身見せても食べないんですよ
いくらこれはすごいもう料理方法やと
もうなかなか簡単じゃないんだとって言ってあげたっても食べないと思いますね
ですから この 2番目のコミュニケーションは成り立たないんですよ
そこで世の中で人間が自分の気持ちをわかってほしいがるんですね
欲しがったってもわかるんでしょうかね
皆様方は子供を育てた経験がありますから
小さい時 子供はおもちゃを持って一生懸命もう遊んでるでしょ
あの気持ちわかりますかね
なんであんなにもうおもちゃにしがみついているんですかと
で 私と一緒に国へ行った子供がいて
日本人の子供がそこで友達とずっと遊んでいたんで
1 日中そこで向こうは何もないんだから
この刀で遊ぶ遊ぶゲームも作って
そこら辺にあった竹か何かで
このちょっと半分割って
もう刀のようにちょっと作ってあげたんです
作ってあげて それで男の子たちが遊んでいたんですよ
もう全然格好悪いし もうただもう包丁で割って
まあ子供たち作ったもんだから
で 日本に帰るときは あの子はあれ
何にもかっこも悪い 何のこともない
あのかっこ悪い竹の半分を持ってきたんですよ
それ持っていかなくちゃカバンに入らないよと
これは捨てちゃえと言っても
あれもう持っていったんです
カバンにも入らなかったんだから
手で持っていったんです
もうかっこ悪くて 私もあれ
でもだからその子供の気持ちはわかりますかと
その子供は日本の子供だから
日本でものすごい立派なおもちゃで遊んでいるでしょうね
ただ破って拾った 竹の半分をね
そんな大事に日本まで持ってくる必要ないでしょうね
日本の竹はもっともっとかっこいいのに
ですから この気持ちはわからないんですよ
一応私はわかったつもりですけど
それつもりだけ 私は理解した
その子供はものすごくもう感激したんですね
遊んでくれて もう日本と違って
もう欧西の人々がもう何の遠慮なし
もう思い存分遊び相手になってくれたんだから
自分が楽しかったというこの刺激は覚えているんですね
だから それはあのくだらない竹に映していて
それからそれ離れたくないとぐらいの気持ちだろうと思いますけどね
それもわかりません なぜなら聞いたんですよ
なんで持っていくんですかと
こんなくだらないものをと言ったら
いえ これは大事です 答えはそれだけ
何が大事ですかと 何にもわからない
そういうことだから  2番目のコミュニケーションってのは残念ながら成り立たないんです
成り立たないんだけど
みんな苦労します 理解しよう
理解しようと ですから
生きることではいろいろトラブル
混乱は起きてきます 何がわかる方法ないんでしょうかね
まああることはあるんだけど
ものすごく危険ですよ
人の気持ちわかっちゃったら
ものすごい落とし穴に落ちるんだから
ある方法ありますよ まあ気持ちを理解する方法っていうのは
で 最後のところになってくると
まあそこら辺 まあ時間があったら説明します
でも自分の責任でやらなくちゃいけない
人の気持ちわかったらもうろくなことにならないことも確かなんです
じゃあ それで 2種類のコミュニケーション
で 次に私はいろんなところで話したことがありまして
それはこのもう大変な難しいポイントなんです
けど まだまだ私もまとめて喋ったことはないし
難しいすぎて私の頭でもまだまだ整理終わってないんです
すごい哲学的ないろんな概念ですから
もうかなり時間かかります
整理して人に分かりやすくするまでは
でも瞑想する方々には
瞑想を教える場合 私はよく言う話があります
で これは何回も何回も皆様が聞いていらっしゃると思いますし
ですから できるだけ新しい人々の顔を見て説明します
で それにはしょっちゅう時間かかる可能性もあります
で 私がバラの花 1本持ってきて皆様に見せる
見せて いかがでしょうか？このバラの花はきれいですかと聞くんです
そうすると 大体皆様方は
うん そうです バラの花は綺麗ですと言うでしょう
ほとんど千人一致で言うでしょうと思います
そこで私たちはみんな同じ意見だと
気持ち通じたんだと 私もバラの花はきれいだと思っている
皆様方もバラの花がきれいだと思っている
ああ まあ気持ち通じましたと
それで気持ち通じるんでしょうかね
はい きれいですという言葉は使いますけど
きれいという感覚がそのその人によって違うんです
全く同じ気持ち生まれるわけじゃないんです
ある人が まあまあ このバラの花は綺麗ですけど
私はもうちょっと大きい花の方が好きですよと言うかもしれません
その人にとってはこのバラの花は綺麗なことはきれいなんで
ちょっと小さすぎじゃないかなと
そういう感じでしょ もう一人の人は
まあこの種類じゃなくてもっと違う種類だったら好きですよと言うかもしれません
このバラの花はきれいですが
私はこの種類ではなくて
違う種類の花がもっと好きですよと言うかもしれません
もう一人の人は この色じゃなくて
白い色か赤色か黄色い色のバラの花なんか好きだよと思うかもしれません
で 我々の気持ちはそういう気持ちなんですよ
そこで言葉でどう思いますか？そのバラの花はきれいですかと聞いたら
はい そうです きれいですよと言っちゃう
やっぱりみんな同じ気持ちだよということで
我々は気持ち通じたんだと錯覚はするんだけど
実際は気持ち通じてないんです
私たちだけの世界があるんですよ
具体的に言えば 私に私とバラの花の世界と皆様とバラの花の世界は違うんです
私は小さい時 見たバラの花というのは
そこら辺にあっちこっちにもあったバラの花であって
別に特別に手を込んで育てたものではなくて
もう勝手に好き勝手に
もう野性的で育てたバラの花で
大きい花やら小さい花は色々あったりして
また虫に食われた花やらね
色々あったり それはすごい香りがある
私が特別に気になったのは
もうバラの花はすごい
もうなんか特別な香りを持ってるんではないかと
だから触ったら手ももう洗わない限りはまた手にもついちゃうんですね
あの香りが で それは私のバラの花についての感覚なんですね
いわゆる形がバラバラで
もうなんかあれはつるですからね
バラっていうのは だからこの庭の塀で覆ってもう大きく伸び
伸びたい放題伸びたりしたりして
で そこで花が咲いちゃったら
そこら辺はもう行ったもんじゃないんですよ
もうすごい香り 香りも強烈になってくるとそれほど気持ちいいものでもないし
そこでまた虫は食べているわ
そこでバラの花 1本取ったっても
中に小さな虫が入り込んで花粉取っているとかね
で 皆様が見ているバラの花は恐らく違うでしょう
まず香りがない それから花びらやらすごい綺麗に整えている
花びらも厚い で 茎というんですか
あれはすごく長い ちゃんと花瓶に立てる
立てられる するのするで
そうやってバラの花をこうやって取るんであって
立つことできません だからどうですかね
私がバラの花はきれいと言っても
皆様方もきれいと言っても
我々の住む世界は違うんですよ
でお母さんがおにぎり作ると
子供がものすごい美味しそうに食べる
よく覚えておいてください
決してお母さんが味わう味わう
子供は味わってないんです
そこで時々お母さんが手の込んだ料理を作ったりしますよ
いろんな調味料を入れたり
いろんな工夫したりとかね
子供は食べないんです
おにぎりちょうだいって言うんです
お母さんが機嫌が悪くなるんだけど
せっかくもう手の込んだ料理を作ったのに
おにぎり おにぎりなんか簡単単純ではないかと
で 小さな子供を育てる場合はよくそういうケースありますよ
母親が心配して いろいろ野菜やらいろんな栄養が入っているものやら
バランスを整えて食べさせたいんだけど
子供は違うんですね 白いご飯と海苔ばっかり食べて
それで終わっちゃうんです
なんでしょうかね あれは
だから味の世界違うんですよ
すごく違うんです 大人が味わうおにぎりの味と
子供が味わうおにぎりの味は違うんですね
ですから このどうやってコミュニケーションできるでしょうかね
みんな自分の世界にいるんです
そこはいくらかは理解できると思います
次に 私は次にこう言うんですよ
バラの花は綺麗ですというあなたは嘘つきや嘘つきです
全然事実を語ってない
真理は語ってない 真理語る人は嘘つきではありません
真理語ってない人は嘘つきやと言ったら
皆様のことを私は嘘つき呼びにする
と 皆様方はそれにはどうせ反対するでしょう
バラの花は綺麗ですと言ったって
なんで嘘ですか それは
だってみんなそう思ってるんではないかといきなり攻撃するでしょう
それで私の反応はこういう反応なんですね
もしバラの花っていうのは綺麗ということは客観的な事実であるならば
普遍的な真理であるならば
バラの花が誰にでも綺麗なはずですよと
どんな人にも綺麗なはずですよと
でも あなたが好きなバラの花を自分飼ってる猫にあげてみてください
猫は全然面白がらないんです
ですから 私にきれいなのに
私は好きなのに なんで私が飼っている猫はそれ嫌いんですかね
だからね 猫の反応は面白くないと
つまらないと なんだこれという感じなんです
まあ一応言ってみれば
もしかすると違うかもしれませんだけど
聞いたことはないんですけど
猫に だからバラの花が綺麗っていうことは
人間だけ勝手な考え方であって
事実ではありません で
バラの花に来て座る 蝶々でもいいし
ミツバチでもいいし 虫でも
ああ 綺麗な花だ こんな綺麗なところで楽しいやという気持ちで来るんですかね
そういう気持ちで全く来ない
ミツバチはあっちへ餌があるんだと
スズメたちに皆様餌をあげたりするでしょ
もうたまにでも別にきれいな餌っていうわけでもなく
そこら辺ちょっと何か捨てちゃえば
パンくずでも捨てちゃえばスズメたちが来て食べる
同じ気持ちで バラの花に満開しているバラの花に虫が飛んでくるんですよ
でも 我々にとってはすごい綺麗な花であって
虫にとってはただの餌場なんですよ
だから餌場という感覚と綺麗な花という感覚というのは随分違うでしょ
だから人間がバラの花は綺麗ですということは
人間だけの好き勝手な考え方であって
決して事実ではありません
で 次に音に行ってみましょう
で 音楽というものがあるんですね
我々はまあ綺麗な音楽です
音楽は綺麗なものですと言うでしょうに
でも人間の音楽は 私は実験してみたんだけど
猫に聞かせてあげたんだけど
ものすごい嫌われたんですね
それをわかったということは
いいことをわかったと
私は猫を追い出したければ音楽を流しちゃう
で 猫は逃げていく そこで私たちにとっては
綺麗な音楽は猫にとっては音楽ではありません
だから まあそういう世界
自分だけの世界で生きているんです
そこで人間 よくこういうことをするんですよ
この花は綺麗でしょ 綺麗でしょうと
他人に押し付ける これ
自分に綺麗ですけど 他人に綺麗っていうことじゃないでしょうに
それ他人に押し付けると
例えば私がバラの花1本持ってきて
ほら これ見てください
このバラの花 すごい綺麗でしょ？って言ったら
相手が私は大嫌いですよと言ったら
私はなんで変な人ですねとかね
おかしいんじゃないか
この人 その人を差別する
おかしい人や だってバラの花は綺麗なのに
と思うんです で 外国人
誰か外国人が日本の方
日本のどこかに家に訪ねたら
日本の方々はやっぱりせっかく来る外国のお客さんだから
ごちそうを作ろうと思っても
鯛のもうそのまま姿で刺身やら作ったりして
これ結構お金かかりますよ
普段自分たちもそんなことを食べません
お金かかりますから せっかく外国の人を接待しようと思っても
高いお金でもうそういういろんな種類の刺身やら
まあ踊り食いの魚やら用意していたとする
で 外国人がすごく気持ち悪くなっちゃって
水もろくに飲まないで
何も食べないで帰ったりする
で そこでこちらはせっかくお金も使ってやったのに
もうなんかすごい気持ち悪くなっちゃうんですね
それ なんでそういうことが起きるか
それは実際にそういうことが起きたんだから言ってるんであって
これ こちらの好き嫌いを相手に押し付けることしちゃったんですよ
そこでトラブルが起きちゃうんですね
そこで逆に私の経験なんです
私は昔 誰か知り合いの人の家に行ったら
まあ奥さんが私はスリランカ人だからね
一生懸命カレー作ったんです
そこで自慢までしたんです
向こうの味に合わせて作ったんだと
私は考えたのは まあなんとか適当な日本の料理を作った方がよかったのにと
食べられないんですよ
国の味に合わせて作ったカレーはあまりにもまずくて
向こうはもっと考えたんですよ
やっぱりこの人は外人だから日本の食べ物は食べられないでしょう
だからせっかく接待するんだから
その人においしいものを作ってあげようと思って作ったんだけど
私に何がおいしいかということはわかるはずがないんですよ
それはあり得ないんです
だから日本のごちそうを食べさせようと思っても失敗する
じゃあ その外国の人が食べてる食べ物を作ってあげようと思ったら
それも失敗する うまくいくわけじゃないんです
まあぐらいかな そういう世界なんです
そこで それと仏教のはどんな関係ですかというと
私たちが もうちょっと音楽に戻ります
日本でよく聞こえた言葉ありますよ
音楽っていうのは交通ですよと
世界の交通の言葉ですよと
音楽だったら言葉を喋らなくても気持ちは通じますよと言って
日本のいろいろ音楽家たちがいろんな福祉活動とか
いろんなことをやっている人々はいろんな国々に行って演奏したりはします
あれ 本当ですか？と 音楽は交通ですか
人間の間では交通じゃないんですよ
音楽も結局はわからないんですよ
だからなんですよ いろんな種類の音楽があるのは
若者はロック音楽好き
ポピュラー音楽好き で
年取ってる人々にとってはそれは面白くない
うるさい で 今も日本ですごい人気爆発の子供たち
17  18歳の子供たち
歌ったりするでしょうね
すごい人気だそうですけど
私も聴いてみたんだけど
なんだこれぐらいですかと
発想もはるかにしない
何言ってるかわからない
歌唱能力はないと自分がそう思っちゃうんですね
ふざけんじゃないよと
下手だったら勉強しなさいよと
学校に行ってという気持ちになる
でも子供の間ではもう猛烈な人気ということは
子供たちに聞こえる感覚と私に聞こえる感覚が違うということなんです
だから音楽にしたっても
我々には好き嫌いあります
皆様は日本風な音楽好きであって
我々インド人がインド文化だから
そのインド風の音楽は好きであって
日本人はそれは好きじゃない
交通手段にはならないんです
リズムさえも違うんですよ
メロディの使い方も違うんです
ですから みんなよく言うんだけど
それは音楽 例えば 若者を二人
三人集めて みんなで仲良くするために
みんな好きな曲でも流して聴きましょうと
だから 三人の若者が同じ曲を回して聴いても
私が言いたいのはコミュニケーションはなってないんだと
それぞれ違う世界にいるんだと
そこまでお分かりになると思います
そこで問題はこういう問題なんですよ
自分が好きなものはみんな好きだと勘違いすること
自分が嫌いなものはみんなが嫌いと勘違いすること
そこで差別ということが生まれるんですよ
差別する で 例えば こちらに座っている方々の一人だけ
正直に もしバラの花が大嫌いな人がいるとしましょう
みんなその人のことを差別するんですよ
変な人だと だからこのそこら辺は問題なんです
この差別意識 全ての苦しみの元はそこなんです
例えば 皆様方 我々は日本人だと思っちゃう
その思った瞬間で他の人々と自分を区別しているんです
そう 私たちは日本人だと思った途端
自分の方が正しいという気持ちが生まれてくる
他の人間は正しくないと
そうすると そこでいろんなもう何といいますか
トラブルが起きちゃうんですね
いろんなトラブルが起きる
だから世の中で 例えば
まあこれ例えばの話だけなんで
例えば姑さんと嫁さんが喧嘩するとしたりする
で 姑さんが自分が姑だと思った瞬間でも差別しているんです
私は嫁やと思ったら そこでも差別感が出ている
そこでぶつかっちゃうんですね
だからそれを理解する一番厳密な方法というのは
バラの花がきれいですよと思った瞬間で
私がもう他人と自分を分かれて差別感を作っているんです
もの分かれになるんです
それはもう大変な心の問題なんです
それで我々はどうしますかと
ものを見たら自分の世界を作る
音を聞いたら自分の世界を作る
味わった途端 自分の世界を作る
それで他人と分かれちゃう
離れる 離れてしまって
自分の気持ちは他人に押し付けようとする
学校になんでいじめがあるんですかね
差別感なんですよ あの人は違いますよと
何か探す もう背が高かったらそれでいじめられる
背があまりあまり背が伸びてないんだったら
もうそれでまたいじめられるかもしれません
ちょっと子供は体太っているったら
それだけでいじめるかもしれません
ちょっと声が高い でっかい
それだけでやられる可能性はあります
だから人間というのは恐ろしく差別感を持っている
その差別感を持っている人々は
みんな自分だけの世界にいるんですよ
あの人の声はでっかい
私は嫌いですと で その人をいじめる
だから私たちはご飯食べる
ご飯はすごく美味しい
だからライオンにもご飯をあげる
あげたらライオンはもう食べるどころか怒る
怒ったら我々はライオンをいじめる
それ正しいんですかね
あるいはライオンが生の肉を食べる
なめながらゆっくりと美味しそうに
私たちは生の肉塊を見たら気持ち悪くなる
ライオンに出す肉っていうのは
スーパーで売っている肉とは違いますからね
綺麗にもうスライスして売っているわけじゃないんだから
そのままぶつ切りにしてライオンに出す
ライオンはそれすごく美味しそうに食べる
それを見たら私たちは気持ち悪くなっちゃって
なんだ この品のないライオンかとかいじめるべきですかね
そういうふうな それは正しくないってみんな知ってますよ
ライオンにそんな寿司なんかあげたっても
食べるわけじゃないんだと
あの海苔巻きとかね で
こちら私が勝手に怒っても
これは美味しい海苔巻きですよと
手作りですよと コシヒカリのご飯で作ったものですよと
何言ったっても ライオンにとってはそれはまあ全然関係ないことで
肉の塊くれればそれで十分です
で それは人間はやりませんだけど
結局人間はこんなことをやっているんです
世の中を見ると宗教争いあるでしょ
あの人は何々宗教 我々は何々宗教
だから戦って殺し合いましょうと
最近まで韓国人が北朝鮮は敵だと
よく思うこと同じ人間なのに
親戚なのに あの人は黒人だ
我々は白人だと思っても殺し合いだ
だから私は白人だと白人が思ったら
もうとんでもない愚か者で
もう差別の塊なんですよ
だから平気で黒人を殺してきたんですよ
だから世の中でこのいかなる微かな問題も
かすかなトラブルもなぜ起こるかというと
心にあるこの差別感なんですよ
だからこの人種差別みたいな大げさなことじゃなくて
もっと厳密に考えてほしい
バラの花がきれいと言った途端
気をつけた方がいいんですよ
これは自分にとってきれいであって
隣にいる人にとってどうか分かりません
隣の人もきれいですよと言っても
まあ分かりませんと それはその人はどんな感じですか
分かりませんと だからお釈迦様がおっしゃっているこの悟りというのは
心の中からこの一切の差別感を取り除く
そうすると誰ともぶつかることはなくなっちゃうんです
そこでバラの花が花を見たら
私たちにとっては何か感情が生まれてくるんですよ
その感情に我々は煩悩というんですね
汚れと心が汚れた それで孤立する
それでも孤独になる その汚れた心
自分の汚れを他人に理解して欲しがっちゃうんですよ
理解してもらわないと怒るんですね
それも心の汚れなんですね
お母さんのことを理解してほしいと思ったら
理解してくれないとお母さんが気持ち悪くなって苛立つんですよ
そういうふうに 私たちはまあ
見ると聞くと味わうといっぱい煩悩を作って自分を孤立させて
孤立したら孤立したところで理解してほしいということを成り立つ
孤立しているんだから
誰も理解してないんだから
だからお願いする 希望する
理解してほしいと もし差別感が生まれなかったならば
その問題は成り立たないんですね
どうも話が難しくなるんだから
なんとか それで言語なんでしょうかね
言葉っていうのは 言葉も差別用語なんですよ
で 言葉は学校で使う言葉
今日は雨ですよという場合の言葉は一旦置いておいて
成り立つコミュニケーションになりますから
普通の言葉っていうのは結局差別用語なんですね
それで私はこう言います
で 太郎さんは あんまりいい人間じゃないと
皆様方は分かったようなふりをする
あ そうですかと 本当はわからないんですよ
もし太郎さんという人がいて
私も知ってます その人のことを相手の人も知ってます
それで私は相手の人にね
あんた知ってますかね
太郎さん あんまりいい人間じゃないんですよって言う
言ったら その人もそうですね
やっぱりいい人間じゃないねと
もうちゃんと賛成してくれる
それでコミュニケーション成り立ったような錯覚
成り立ってない で 私がどういうわけで
どういう気持ちで良い悪い
いい人間じゃないかと言ったかと
それも私の世界であって
相手の世界はまた別であって
で 言葉上 なんとなくうまくいったような気がする
うまくいかないんですよ
それで世の中はね いろんなことを言うでしょう
一つも成り立たないんですよ
大変なもうきつい問題なんです
うまくいかないということ
お釈迦様がおっしゃっている世の中にはありとあらゆる苦しみ
お釈迦様はおっしゃるんですよ
国と国と戦う 民衆と民衆を戦う
で 宗教と宗教も戦う 男と女が戦う
兄弟もお互いに戦う 夫婦もお互いに戦う
いつでもぶつかり合って
戦って戦って 世の中でももう恐ろしいほど殺戮が起きてきたんでしょう
歴史上 今も起きてるでしょう
これからもみんな人殺しやってるでしょう
全てものすごいつまらない
いい加減な考え方なんですよ
昔 日本もよく戦争したでしょ
日本の国の中でも地方の名前違うだけで
あちらの大名は何々さん
こちらの大名は何々 こちらこれだこれ
そうやって名前違うだけで戦う
本当につまらないと思いますけど
例えばイスラエルだったら
もう最近までずっとユダヤ
パレスチナ人と殺し合いやったりしたでしょう
今もうもう仲はすごい悪い
何の根拠もないんですよ
ただ 自分たちの主観の問題なんですよ
で 例えば西洋の宗教 キリスト教というものがあるでしょうに
その方々は昔はね 自分たちが正しいと思ったんですよ
どうやって正しいと思ったかってのはいい加減ですよ
他の宗教なんか全然勉強したこともない
ただ 自分の周りにあった宗教を勉強して
あ これ偉大なる神言って
アジアまで来て 人を殺して殺して殺して
野蛮人だ 野蛮人だと 限りなく人殺しやってきたんです
何のためかというと 慈悲の神様のために殺してるんだと
人を殺して隣人を愛しなさいよ
え？何なのかと ちょっとした変な考え方でしょ
私たちが唯一の神様は信じているんだという錯覚
で 黒人ね 奴隷にしたりしてすごい殺されたんでしょうに
だから世の中でいかに悲しいか
いかに苦しいかと そこで政治システムにしたっても
一向にどんな国でもうまくいかないんですよ
アメリカの例を取ってみたっても
共和党が政権取ったら
民主党と言うんですか
向こうはもうとにかく足を引っ張ろうと
何でも壊してやるぞとと頑張っちゃう
民主党が政権取ったら
共和党がまたもう 何でしょうかね
あれは 日本の国会にしたっても
国民のために何か決めようと思ったっても
なかなかうまくいかない
いろんなところからいろいろ反対をする
なぜでしょうかと 時々理由がないんですよ
理由はある場合もありますけど
ただ 自分の党の考え方とは違うと
で ただそれだけのことで
例えば素晴らしい意見は共産党の人が出したとする
頭から否定する 聞こうともしない
なぜか 共産党の人だから
で 我々はそういう風にも徹底した差別人間なんです
差別ないのは完全たる悟り開いた人々だけなんです
だから人間であるならば
もう差別の塊 差別の塊だから
もう苦しみも喧嘩ももう絶えません
ずっと苦しんで生きてなくちゃいけない
母親と子供がなんで喧嘩するかというと
お互いの世界の中に閉じ込まれているんだからなんです
それはまあ ある特別な訓練しない限りは治らない問題なんです
で そこでお釈迦様だったら
人の気持ちを理解しなさい
理解しなさいということじゃなくて
喋る場合は気をつけてね
私がこう思いますよと
それだけ言ってくださいと
それで相手が私は違う意見だよと言ったっても
腹が立つなよと   だから私には私の意見があって
相手には相手の意見があって
それで終わるはずなんですよ
私はこういう意見ですと
で 相手の人 私はこういう意見ですと
そういう意見を言っただけで理解はしないんだから
結局は通じませんだから
だから腹が立つ必要も舞い上がる必要もないんです
私も同じ意見ですよと言っても
本当は同じ意見じゃないんですよ
あの 自分たちの目的でもって同じ意見だというだけ
で 何かいい例が思い出せませんだけど
例えば 私がどこかへ出かけたいと思っている
それである人が部屋に来て
まあ明日休みもありますから
まあどこかへで行った方がいいなと私も思ってますけど
と言ったら 私は私も同じ意見ですよ
明日休みなからどこかへ出かけた方がいいんですよと言って
私はまあ もし私が例えばどこでしたっけ？横浜に行きたいんですけど
どうですかね 横浜の方にドライブしたらと
やっぱり同じ意見だ 行きましょうと言っちゃいます
それは嘘ですよ それで私は横浜へ行きたいんだからそう言うんであって
あの人はただ出かけたい
宛てが決まってない そこをうまくすり替えして
じゃあ横浜の方どうでしょうか？と言うんであって
で  2人仲良く横浜に行って帰る
本当に仲良くかと 時々自分に別な目的があって
それを達成するために相手の意見に賛成する場合があるんです
これは一番よく見えるのは
この政治の世界で いろんな党が統合する場合は
それぞれ別な目的があるんですよ
その人 なんで賛成するかっていうこと
その人だけの世界なんです
それは本当の世界のあり方なんです
生命のあり方なんです
暗い言葉で言えば 誰一人も誰もわかってないと
今もすでに我々は全然コミュニケーションしてない
全く孤立しているんです
それで私の話を聞いてびっくりする必要ないんですよ
別に 今までも皆様方は誰ともコミュニケーションを取ったことがないんですよ
別にそれでもって何か起きたわけないんだからね
だからこれから別にコミュニケーションしないまま
できないままで死ぬまで生きてやれます
物分かれのままで まあ時々あるでしょう
20年夫婦一緒にいても相手の気持ちは分からなかったとかね
よくあるでしょうね 別にそれは夫婦生活に何の関係もないんですよ
まあそこそこ接点があるところで
接点でもなんとか何とかという自分の世界で生きているんです
だから私はわざとこの全く悪い
もうとんでもない失礼なことを言っているわけじゃなくて
普通に世の中の人間の心のある働きを言っているだけ
そこで私が文句言っているのは
相手のことを理解したんだと勘違いしないでくださいと
自分のことを理解したと勘違いしないでくださいと
その勘違いしちゃうと
我々は自分の意見を相手に押し付けようとする
みんなの賛成を得ようとする
そこでみんないじめられるんですよ
そうすると我々は苦しみを味わっちゃうんですよ
だからそこら辺気をつけましょうと
例えば皆様方は日本人だと
それでいいんです それだけで
で ただの言葉だけですよと
それでもって日本人学
日本人論なんか作ったりして
他人を差別して 隣の国に戦争
もう戦い挑むというのは
もうあまりにもバカバカらしい
ある人わけで 私はキリスト教の信者さんで
だいだいどうぞやってくださいと
それで十分です それであなたもどうですかと言ったら
それは大きなお世話 だから私たちはこの他人を支配しようとするんだからね
意見通ったと わかってくれたと
わかってくれたんだから
言うことをやりましょうと
のは それでトラブルは起こる
それでお釈迦様おっしゃっているのは
この普遍的な真理だけ考えてくださいと
言葉っていうのは普遍的じゃないんです
例えば ご飯という言葉を使っちゃうと
皆様と私が同じ意見ではありません
皆様方が思っているご飯と私が思っているご飯違いますから
そういうことだからね
結構日本でこのカタカナ言葉使うでしょ
日本語の言葉あるにも関わらず
それは意味が違うんだからなんです
で 写真機と言うべきところでカメラと言うでしょうに
やっぱり写真機と言っちゃったら意味が違うんですよ
カメラで言ったらまた違う
よく使うストレスという言葉がありますね
それには何かもう日本語の言葉はあると思いますよ
でも日本語の言葉を使っちゃうと
意味時の意味とストレスというカタカナ言葉を使っちゃう時の意味が違うんです
ですから この例えばヨーロッパ人がいて
こちら私がいて 皆様がいて
みんなでまあご飯について語ると
いきなりご飯という言葉が耳に触れる
ヨーロッパの方も日本語がわかっている
私も日本語わかる 皆さんは日本語わかる
それで同じ日本語でご飯という言葉を言った途端
我々は同じ気持ちが生まれるかと
全く違う ヨーロッパ人にとっては
この一つ一つの食事は違うんですよ
ブレックファストがあって
ディナーがあるでしょうに
あの人々はどちらにどちらをご飯にするでしょうかね
私もわかりません それでランチという言葉があるでしょうに
ヨーロッパ人 日本語をしゃべるヨーロッパ人が
まあ私たちもよくご飯食べますよと言っても
何を思いますか？ランチ思いますか？ブレックファスト思いますか？ディナー思いますかね
でも日本人にとってはご飯食べますと言ったらまた違う意味
でも日本語でもディナーという言葉があるんでしょ
ディナーイコールご飯じゃないでしょ
そういうことで まあ言葉を使っても
まあ本当に我々はお互い
てるんですかと あの子供たちの会話は一番いいんですよ
なぜかというと 誰も聞いてない
みんな喋る そこは一番健康的な会話なんです
ある男の子がね 私にも悩み事あると言って話したところで
まあいろいろ悩み事を全部解決してあげたんだけど
最初にあなたに残っている悩みは何ですか？と聞いたら
うまく喋れないんだと
言ったら まあそう これ大変だと私も言って
そんなにうまく喋る必要ありますか？といきなりびっくりして聞いたんですよ
聞いたら やっぱり喋るとすごく下手で
みんなに嫌われちゃうし
だからすごく頭の中でモヤモヤしてなかなか喋れないんだと
私の答えはそれでいい
喋らなくても 君は喋らないでくださいと
なぜかというと 君の友達はみんなペラペラペラペラ喋るんだけど
誰も聞いてないんだと
君もそちらに入っちゃって
またペラペラペラペラうるさい
うるさいだけですよと
だから黙っていた方が
みんなの話を聞いているような感じでいた方が
もっとあなたのことはみんなに愛されるんだと
なぜかというと みんな他の人を喋るだけ誰も聞いてないでしょうに
特に女の人の話もそうでしょうね
よく喋る うるさいというと誰も聞いてないんですよ
ものすごくうるさくて
もう日々我を 全部そういう声なんですよ
もう自信じゃないんですよ
だから喋るということはそういうことなんです
自分が感情が舞い上がってきて
ストレス溜まるんですよ
ストレス溜まったらどうにもならないんですね
それを吐くんですよ 喋るとよくそういうことなんです
別に相手が理解してもしなくても
そんなことを構わずとにかく喋る
止まらないで喋ると ですから
お釈迦様はおっしゃるのは
できるだけ言葉は少なくしなさいと
ものすごく少なくしなさい
それからはっきりと自分言うことをはっきりしなさいと Yes
のはっきりすること それから何か言いたいという気持ちが生まれたら
お釈迦様の場合はまずこういうふうに考えてほしい
すぐ喋るんじゃなくて
一旦停止して言いたい
これは言うべきかないか
まず決める やっぱり言った方がいいと思ったとする
それだったら私はどんな順番でこれ言いますかと言って
ちゃんとこの編集してカットして
必要な言葉だけ喋って終わった方がいいと
感情だけで喋ると終われないんですよ
夫婦喧嘩みたいに 疲れて終わりますよ
別に喧嘩冷めたわけじゃないんです
もうこれ以上喋れないんですよ
それに疲れてやめるんです
もし体力があったら さらにもういちゃっちゃうんです
だからろくに喧嘩もできないんですよ
本当の喧嘩だったら 一言二言で喧嘩できます
そういうことだから 喋る場合はもう量少なく
それから喋るべきかないかと判断して
喋るならば順番正しく
喋った方がいい 喋っても相手が分からなかったらまあそれでいいんです
いくらか分かったならば
それはそれでもいいんです
自分がそれによって気持ち悪くなったり
怒ったり 舞い上がったりする必要はないんです
うん まあ大体まあ言葉っていうのは
コミュニケーションっていうのは
まあまたいろいろテーマは細かいたくさんありますけどね
たくさんありすぎて それでまた話に戻ります
それで話終了しますけど
この相手の気持ちがわかる方法はあるんです
で 仏教でも他心通という言葉がありますね
他人の心を読めると 瞑想する人々にできる能力なんですよ
その他心他心術という言葉を聞いちゃうと
普通の方が あっ これありがたい話やと思うかもしれません
なぜかって？これ超能力だから
人の心をすぐ読めるんだと
だから支配力ある人々にとっては
支配欲ある人々にとってはもうもってのほかということ
大変ありがたがる話ですけど
前に注意したように それほどありがたい話ではないんです
確かに瞑想とか修行しちゃうと
人の気持ちは理解できるようになる
で 修行方法では どうしても自分の心だけじゃなくて
他人の心も理解する必要もあります
だから修行なんかはそういう方向へどんどんどんどんステップ
ステップアップしていくんですよ
でもそこは俗世間から考えるように
あの人を思って考えていることを私がわかりますだとかね
あの人のことはもうすぐ読めるんだと
私に他心術あるんだからと
そういう汚れた話ではないんです
まず 修行によってこの固定概念
それを破っちゃうんですよ
固定概念を破るということは
あれは音楽です これは鳥の声ですっていうのは差別化感なんですよ
あれは車の音ですと 我々は区別差別する
見る時でも これは花です
これは建物です これは食べ物ですとか
頭で思っちゃうでしょ
概念で その概念の世界はすべて差別用語
概念持っちゃうと で そこで修行して
その概念をまず破る 耳に触れるのは鳥の声でもなく
音楽でもなく 人の話し言葉でもなく
車の音でもなく ただの音だけですと
具体的に実際に耳に触れたのは音だけですと
その音だったら猫の耳にも触れるんだと
だから猫の耳にも同じ音が触れて
私の耳にも同じ音が触れる
その音の音について作る世界
主観的な妄想世界 あれは嘘なんです
事実ではありません 例えば車の音を聞いて
私は気持ち悪いとか 音楽を聴いてああ
気持ちいいとか思っても
猫はどのように思っているか我々はわかりません
でも 一つだけ事実はあります
猫の耳にも音が触れる
私の耳にも音が触れる
そこで我々はわざと訓練して
妄想概念使わないようにする
音だけ見えるものは区別しない
見えているだけ そこで花
バラの花 1本持ってきたら
バラの花といった途端
もう差別用語なんですけど
もうバラの花と一時的に我々いう何か対象を持ってくる
持ってきて 私と猫がお互いに顔を合わせて座って前に置いておく
置いておくと 私にもそれ見える
猫にもそれ見える バラの花ではないんです
言ったら それ私だけの勝手な考え方で猫とは通じません
猫と通じるのは見えるというところだけ
技術はそこで終わっちゃうんですよ
音を聞こえた そこで終わり
猫にもそこで終わり 我々は失敗する
何を聞こえた どう感じた
何考えたとかね 好きか嫌いかとかね
それはすべて幻想の世界
幻の世界 自分だけの主観の世界
そこを破ったところで
次にこういうふうにわかるんですよ
音を触れたら 自分にどんな感じが生まれたかと
時々きれいな音だと反論する
判断しちゃうと気持ちよくなる
それまた次にすごく理解する
嫌な音やと判断してしまっちゃったら
なんとか嫌な気持ちになる
そこで猫にしたっても
音についてその 2つの判断があるんです
そこら辺で共通しているんですよ
似ているんです で 私がバラの花を見て喜んじゃう
で 好きだから喜びの感情が生まれる
猫がゴキブリを見て喜びの感情が生まれる
そこら辺で似ているんです
猫と私がバラの花を見たら
同じ感情は生まれません
私が自分の机の上にバラの花一本立てて
それを見ながらいると
自分飼っている猫にもゴキブリ 1匹捕まってあげて
前に置いてあげると で
2人とも楽しいんです
そこら辺が通じるんです
そこで人の心で何を理解できるかというと
まず自分が怒っていること
怒りがあることを理解する
経験する どんな気持ち
どんな感じかと 他人が怒っても同じことなんです
同じ感じなんですね 自分が欲は欲出したらどんな気持ちかと
それ理解する そうすると他人も欲出したらそういう感じだと理解する
そこで他心数で読めるのはそこら辺なんです
この人の心に怒りがある
この人の心に欲がある
この人の心に無知がある
この人の心には まあまあいろいろ困沈とか睡眠とか
そういうものに今状態は混乱状態ですよと
この人の心は今すごく小さくなっているんだと
弱いんだと この人の心は今ちょっと強いんだと
そこら辺は通じる だから我々は何も喋らなくたっても
人を見たら ああ あんたなかなか元気ですねと雰囲気で言うでしょ
それ通じてるんです 心は明るく回転している
でもわからないのは なんであんた今日は異常に元気ですか？というところはわからない
なんか今日は元気そうやっていうぐらいはわかります
なんかちょっと悲しそうやと
それはすぐ通じるんです
喋らなくても だからこの万人に普遍的な感情は通じられます
すべての生命に普遍的な感情は
それは怒り むさぼり 無知
嫉妬 憎しみなどなど 悪い方向へ言えば
いい方向へ言えば明るさ
活発性 力強さ 元気ということぐらいでしょうね
で 私たちは理解してほしいと思うのは
そういうものじゃないんです
でも 子供はお母さんが怒っているとちゃんと知ってますよ
お母さんは機嫌が悪いんだと
ニコニコと喋っても知ってるんで
それだけは そこで父親があなたのために言ってるのではないかと
だから話を聞けと言っても
子供は聞かないでしょ
本当は父親がそれをあなたのために言ってるわけじゃないんですよ
怒ってるんです 怒ってるんだから聞かないんです
怒ってるんだと キレてるんだと
子供の反応はそれだけ
そこで時々あなたのために言ってるんですよと言ったっても
本当は本人が自分のために言ってるんですよ
子どもが悪くなっちゃったら
自分にとってはすごくまずいんですよ
自分にとって我慢できないんです
自分の面子は立たないんですよ
だから子どもはしっかり元気で
もうよく頑張ってほしい
結局 それ自分のためなんですよ
そういう場合も子どもは聞かない
本当に子どものために言う場合は
お父さんの言葉は変わっちゃうんですよ
その場合は 君 それでいいというふうに聞くんです
私は知りませんだから
君のことだから 君がいいと思うならばね
どうしようもないと 知りませんという感じになるんですよ
そうすると理解する これは私の問題だと
本当に父親が私のことを思っているんだと
だったら父親の方が頭がいいんだから
私はもう何も経験ないんだから
じゃあ聞いてみようと
その場合は 私はこういうこともやりたいと
こういうこともやりたいんだけど
なかなか困って何やればいいでしょうかと父親に相談する
父親が学問を決めちゃったら
進学ルートを決めちゃったら
これはもう父親のエゴであって
子どもは訳がない ですから
我々は一番隠したがるもの
自分のエゴ 自分の怒り
自分のわがまま 自分の欲望
自分の嫉妬 そういうものは思い存分他人に通じてるんです
残念ですけど 私はインチキで人が理解してほしいと思うものは
インチキで実際しないんですよ
本当は怒っているんだけど
随分落ち着いていると理解してほしいんですよ
それは成り立たないんです
じゃあ最後に聞きますけど
皆様方は自分のことをどう思ってほしいんですか？他人が
どう思ってほしいんですか？結局はよく思ってほしいでしょ
いい人間だと 立派な人やと思ってほしいでしょうに
だからわかってるでしょうに
ないものを思って欲しがるんだけど
情報伝達っていうのは発見した伝達なんですよ
電波がなければ携帯電話は鳴りません
だから心には反応を起こしません
例えば 私が本当に怒っているのに
こうやってニコッとしている
それを体は口がそうニコッとしているだけで
私の心から出す電波が怒りなんですよ
だから その電波が相手の心にぶつかって
相手の心に反応を起こすんですよ
だから正しい反応を起こすんです
私はせっかく笑っているのに
向こうは機嫌が悪くなる
攻撃する で 私はなんであんたそんなに怒るんですか？と相手に聞くんだけど
本当は怒っているのはこちらなんですよ
私はこんなに落ち着いて喋っているのに
なんであんた怒るんですかと
だからこのコミュニケーションというのは
私は最初から成り立たないと言ったんだけど
本当はもうとっくに成り立っているんですよ
それは避けられないんです
私は大きい声で喋ったら
皆様の耳に触れることは避け
かね だから私の心から実際にある感情を電波として出してるんです
そこでみんな自分の心という携帯電話で全部受けてるんですよ
だからテレビで ４チャンネルを回しちゃったら
１０チャンネル映るはずがないでしょ １
局でニュース流れてる場合は
やっぱり１局で１チャンネルで映画見ようかなと思ったってできますか？できません １
チャンネルで映画見たければ １
チャンネルが映画を放送している時見なくちゃいけないんですよ
そのように我々はずっと心の感情
気持ちを電波として出してるんです
出してる電波はそのままみんな受け取っているんです
だから 本当の答えは コミュニケーションは成り立つか立たないということじゃなくて
もうとっくにぴったしと成り立ってるんです
問題は 我々 それ嫌なんですよ
人のことを嫉妬するんだけど
知られてほしくない だって言い訳言うんですよ
だってあの人悪いでしょ
あんなことを許していいと思いますか
あなたは とかね 別に私は嫉妬する気持ちはないんだけどと言っても
それは分からないんですよ
嘘だと 実際の心の波動じゃないんだから
そこで皆様よく経験あるでしょ
時々 ある人々と一緒にいると
よく喋らなくても気持ちがいい
ある人々と一緒にいると
すごく丁寧に相手が喋るんだけど
すごく丁寧に敬語を使って謙虚として喋るんだけど
なんかどこかで気持ち悪い
なんか嫌 あれ何でしょうかね
言葉じゃないんですよ
心が出してる波動なんですよ
だからそこを読み取ってください
あまり面白くないかもしれませんだけど
私は全然面白くないんですよ
すごい苦労しているんだから
別に知りたくないんです
人の心なんかは でも知らなくてはならないという羽目になっている
で 訓練上 それはもうもう訓練もしているし
だからもうもう零点五倍ぐらいの
時間でもうぴったし読めるんですけど
でもこちらも辛いんですよ
なぜならば みんな余計なことで悩んだり
バカみたく苦しんだり
もう何なのかと もうちょっとしたことで治るでしょうと言っても
私知ってますよ この人は大した問題で悩んでるわけじゃないんだけど
やっぱり 20年かかるんだと
この人だったらもう 5 年間苦労しなきゃもう治らないかと
時々ある人々だって この人だったらもうしがみついて
24時間つきっきりで面倒を見なきゃもう治らない頑固な心やとかわかるんだから
それできないでしょ 私にとっては
だから決していい気持ちじゃないんです
すごい機嫌が斜めなんです
皆様より一歩ちょっと上ということになりません
できれば相手の気持ちはわからない方がいいと
その方が楽なんです 心配しなくても済みますから
そこで私はもう逆さ戻したら
全ての経典が頭の中でぐるぐる回ったり
その人にその人に合うように教えをどのように言えばいいかと
こう言ったらまた反応する
じゃあこういう風に言います
それで反応したらこういう風に言いますよと
かなり頭の中はものすごい強力なコンピューターのように回転させないと
だから普通 皆様考えるよりは
もしかすると私はもう何万倍も早く考えてるんですよ
時々自分の体にも耐えられなくなっちゃう
1 秒間で考える量を考えちゃうと
思っちゃうと大変やと
それぐらい苦労しなくちゃいけないんですね
だから他人の心をわかるっていうことは
それほどありがたいことじゃないんですが
悟りに必要なぐらいはわかってほしい
いわゆるみんな欲で馬鹿を見ているんだと
怒りで馬鹿を見ているんだと
苦しんでいるんだと 何のこともないんだと
好き嫌いなんかは意味がないんですよ
でも好き嫌い 激しい わがまま
わがまま自体もものすごいあほらしいんですよ
でもわがままはする みんな自分が正しいと思っている
でも聞いたらあなたそう思ってますかと
いえ 全然とんでもないと言うんだけど
本当はそう思っている
結局自分が正しいくはないんだと
自分というものもないんだとわかったところで
すべての問題解決するのに単純なのに
それをやらない ですから
そこらへんぐらいは理解しておけば
悟りにはすぐ早く至って
心は清らかになって安らぎを体験することができるんです
それで話は終了いたしますけど
コミュニケーションは一応成り立ってはいるんです
それは本当は思ってほしくないもの
わかってほしくないものはみんなわかっているんですよ
我々はわかってちょうだい
わかってちょうだいと思っている
自分の主観的な概念は誰一人もわかってくれません
それは不可能です なぜならば心に反応起きません
電波を出してないんだから
私はあなたのことを本当に心配しているんだよと口で言っても
心の中で心配 気持ちなければ通じません
なぜかで 私ほど悪口を言う人間は世の中にないぐらいなんですけど
もう国に帰ったら 弟子たちやら周りの信者さんたちやら
言いたい放題のことを言うんですよ
皆様も私の言葉きついと思ってるでしょ
皆様にはすごい親切なんですよ
こんなもんじゃないんですよ
これ  100万倍もきついんですよ
国に帰ったら喋る言葉なんか
みんなビビることはもうもうきりがないんです
それで不思議なことを誰も怒らないんですよ
普通だったら日本のお寺だったら
もう信者さんに檀家さんにとしてはすごく遠慮するでしょうね
私はそうじゃない 狂暴
あんたそう言うんですかと
という そんな感じで この最近も行った時
ものすごいさんざん怒って叱ったりしたんだけど
みんな何のこともじっと聞いて
じゃあまあ時間ですから帰りますと
何のことも帰るんです
なぜかというと あれ 怒ってさんざんのことを言ってますけど
この基本的なところで
まあお互いのいろいろ過ち
弱いところとかね それを直すべきではないかと
直しましょうと みんなで頑張ろうと
本当は私は信者さんのことも
弟子たちのことも 全く父親のように愛情があるんです
だから向こうは困るとこちらがもっと困るんですよ
そういうことを知ってるんだから
これは通じているんだから
で もうだからもう向こうは何も怒ったり喧嘩したりはできません
で この間も弟子たちを集めて 5 分ぐらい喋っちゃったんだけど
散々言って いきなり君たちにも言いたいことがあったら言ってみなさいと
返しとして 私に対して誰一人何も言わない
結局私は弟子たちのことをすごく父親のようにもうもう心配して言ってるんだっていうことはわかってるんだから
で その代わりにもうみんな謝って
もうもう解散したんだけど
本当は一方的に叱っただけなんですけど
あまり情報も知らないでこちらでいるんだから
ですから やっぱりこの言葉ではなくて
心は読めるんですね だから皆様方に一つ提案があります
優しい心を作ってください
知られても何のこともない
いつきし ってください
嫉妬 憎しみ 怒りなんかはもう毒だと
ゴミだと 汚物だと思って心から捨ててください
人を憎しんだり 嫌になったりすることは
まあ自分が気持ち悪くなったと
自分が汚物の中のものを落ち込んだような感じで思ってください
嫌な人だと思った途端
自分がもう便所の中に落ちたような感じで思って嫌ってください
優しさ 慈しみ みんな幸せでいてほしいと
ゴキブリでもアリでも犬でも猫でも
自分の子供でも誰でも生命で同じだと
みんな幸せで幸福で 楽しく明るくいてほしいと
私の人生のモットーはそれだよと
私には敵がいませんと
嫌な人もいませんと そういう気持ちを育てた方がすごく楽なんです
そうするとコミュニケーションという問題は成り立ちません
そういうことで話を終了いたします
どうもありがとうございました